some members of the United States Secret  Service which is involved among other  things in protecting the president and  the president's family have been found  to be part of the far-right extremist  group The Oath Keepers some of whom were  involved in the January 6th Capital  riots now to be clear  not that secret service members were  involved in the riots Oath Keepers of  which some secret service members are  apart have been involved in the January  6th riots this is very scary stuff and  there was a story floating around not  long ago that Joe Biden was cautious  about what he would say around members  of the Secret Service it seems like it  really wasn't as paranoid as some people  thought